kanoon is back in Japan after making an
unusual zigzag move the tropical storm
made landfall on the southern island of
Kyushu Wednesday packing Winds of up to
108 kilometers an hour thousands of
households have been left without
electricity hundreds of flights canceled
and trains suspended it's also affected
the ceremony in Nagasaki marking the
78th anniversary of the U.S Atomic
bombing for the first time in 60 years
the event was held indoors most
survivors and victims families were
unable to attend prime minister
fumiyokshida who was also absent due to
the extreme weather spoke via video link
with the division of the International
Community over nuclear disarmament
deepening and Russia's nuclear threats
continuing the road to achieving a world
free of nuclear weapons is becoming even
more difficult
Southern Japan is still recovering from
Canon's landfall last week
it slammed into Okinawa at typhoon
strength killing two people and cunning
power to a third of homes in the
prefecture here in Tokyo we're bracing
for another storm
typhoon land is expected to reach
Central Japan on Sunday at the beginning
of the peak summer holiday season
warnings have been issued for possible
landslides flooding in low-lying areas
and rough Seas kanoon is projected to
reach South Korea's southern coast on
Thursday authorities have already
canceled flights and closed dozens of
sea routes and Roads
Montgomery Al Jazeera Tokyo